we are headed into a very big music
weekend here in town thousands for the
life of beautiful and i heart radio
music festival i should say hundreds of
thousands absolutely they're all here
both will surely help local businesses
they need that boost and we have a live
look now from life is beautiful getting
underway in downtown las vegas you need
to show your proof of the covet
vaccination or a negative covid test to
get in there will also be testing sites
there all weekend looks like the crews
are handling the incoming crowd quite
efficiently and the iheart radio music
music festival also going on it is at
t-mobile very exciting they'll have the
daytime stage for concerts tomorrow at
area 15. the first event at the grounds
there they are requiring proof as well
of full cove vaccination or a negative
test there is a lot to unpack when it
comes to traffic ahead of this busy
weekend traffic anchor nate tannenbaum
is here with some helpful hints
the bottom line unless you're actually
going to either life is beautiful in
downtown las vegas or the outdoor part
of iheart music at area 15 you probably
should avoid both areas now we're going
to go to downtown first we know things
are serious when they started closing
streets a couple of days ago we are
recommending that festivalgoers check
the life is beautiful website or app for
parking information and pretty much the
same thing goes for the i heart music
festival this is an area 15 that's off
of rancho between desert inn and sahara
we also think you should continue to
check our website for all those links
and that is on eight newsnow dot com
back to you